we have to start today with russia and
ukraine where there are both reasons to
be
uh absolutely horrified about what may
be coming to the planet over the next
several weeks but also some reasons to
be cautiously optimistic and we're going
to talk about both and we should
understand both
on the one hand the bad
we are facing what kamala harris calls a
real possibility
of what boris johnson refers to as the
biggest european war since world war ii
we have no reason to believe at this
point
that russia and putin were telling the
truth about pulling back with there has
not been any independently verified
evidence that suggests that's what's
taking place despite the claims last
week and there is reason to believe
according to president joe biden
that vladimir putin has already made the
decision
to invade ukraine
now i don't know if we need to
refresh the entire situation
but
russia points to so-called nato
expansion and support of ukraine from
nato as an act of aggression
the
actual aggressor in the case of russia
and ukraine
is clearly putin but there are some who
say his aggression is justified and this
includes
i mean in the u.s some on the right and
some on the left for different reasons
many of them victims of different types
of propaganda which we will talk about
but let's go to some of what world
leaders are saying and it doesn't really
matter
whether you like these world leaders i
don't particularly love either of them
um but let's talk about what is being
said here is a
british prime minister
boris johnson take a listen the plan
that we're seeing
is for something that could be
really the biggest war in europe since
1945 and just in terms of sheer scale
you're looking at um
not just an invasion through the east
through the through the don bass but uh
according to the intelligence
intelligence that we're seeing coming
down from the north down from belarus
and actually encircling uh kiev itself
as yes so what it's
it is the type of thing
that
the circumstances are completely
different than world war ii but in terms
of the scale
in european countries
it would be if it's the worst case
scenario
clearly the biggest war in europe since
world war ii kamala harris also
commenting on this from the munich
security conference over the weekend i
mean listen guys
we're talking about the potential for
war in europe
i mean let's really take a moment to
understand the significance of what
we're talking about
it's been over 70 years and through
those 70 years as i mentioned yesterday
there has been peace and security
we are talking about the real
possibility of war in europe now there
has not been total peace and security in
europe and we have had a number of
different uh civil wars within europe
and oh okay but the the point is clear
which is this type of
large war involving multiple countries
has not been seen in europe since world
war ii
so our position
is for us very clear
which is as a leader which we have been
bringing together the allies
working together
around our collective and unified
position
that we would
all not just prefer we desire we believe
it is in the best interest of all
that there is a diplomatic end now
unfortunately
um
foreign diplomacy is not kamala harris's
area of expertise
but it actually is joe biden's to a
great degree and we're going to talk
about that in this in the next segment
but if this were to happen and i hope it
doesn't i don't want a war i don't want
u.s troops in ukraine i don't i don't i
don't want any of it okay
this would be disastrous
even for americans in so many different
ways like we talk about supply chain
issues just you wait now you might say
well david sir we don't really get stuff
from russia no that's true but much of
europe's energy comes from russia and if
you see
this conflict escalate it would be
economically devastating for russia for
sure because they would likely stop
getting a ton of that econo european
money they depend on
but europe would have energy issues
those energy issues will translate into
supply chain issues and it's going to be
bad for the supply chain issues we've
been experiencing here energy pricing
issues just you wait if you're upset
about gas prices right now
chaos in the stock markets everyone's
401ks retirement accounts it is going to
be insanity and i hope it doesn't happen
now what is the hope well the hope is
that putin realizes even though europe
depends on his energy
that he depends on europe's money
and that he realizes the economic cost
will be incredibly high the only problem
is that putin
in order to maintain his authoritarian
strongman
sort of uh delusion
he has placed himself in a tough
situation if he does invade it is very
clear the costs are going to be massive
the cost will be massive elsewhere in
the world too we will suffer too but on
the one hand if putin does invade the
costs are going to be massive on the
other hand is he does if he doesn't does
he look weak
so
uh that is where the biden negotiations
that may be coming together will be
interesting and i'll talk about that in
a moment in terms of domestic politics
in the u.s the republican party seems to
trust putin more than our own
intelligence services and it doesn't
mean our intelligence services haven't
been wrong in the past or haven't done
bad things they've been wrong and
they've done bad things but uh the
republican party increasingly seems to
be the party of putin which is bizarre
we also need to stop perpetuating the
falsehood that russia hasn't really done
anything with ukraine yet i mean
remember russia invaded ukraine when
they took crimea
they're effectively occupying eastern uk
ukraine via proxies uh in a couple of
areas
and when they did the crimean annexation
the us and most of the world said that
was really bad that you did that uh but
after after you know saying that it was
basically allowed to happen i'm not
advocating that it should have been time
to bomb russia or i'm just saying that
happened and here's one of the most
important things
we need to
get more exposure
to the reality that there's a russian
propaganda campaign that's fracturing
the united states politically and it is
designed to if russia were to invade
ukraine fully tomorrow whatever that
means in the end
you would see
a huge portion of the online us
appear to support russia you would see a
lot of it and
there would likely be the follow-on
effect
that
republicans in congress will oppose
anything joe biden does not necessarily
because all of them support russia
although i think a bunch of them do and
they don't even really understand why
but because republicans are unified in
trying to prevent joe biden from doing
anything and they see it as a pathway to
returning to power so this is a
dangerous combination russia runs
propaganda campaigns to make many on the
american right and and many on the left
default to or support vladimir putin or
at least stop short of criticizing him
and this will have the effect of
emboldening republicans
to continue opposing and trying to block
anything joe biden wants to do even if
what joe biden wants to do is stop a war
between russia and ukraine and so that's
what we're going to talk about next
major news in the last 6 to 10 hours
joe biden has agreed to meet with
russian president vladimir putin in
principle if putin has not invaded
ukraine at the time that the meeting or
summit would take place
and this is interesting because to some
degree you could say well russia has
kind of already invaded ukraine
and that has different meanings
depending on what you're referring to
whether it's crimea or whether it's
these uh um individual explosions that
are being misattributed okay we we can
define that a few different ways but the
point is
if putin does not invade ukraine
however it is that we are defining that
joe biden has agreed in principle to
meet with with vladimir putin now joe
biden is kind of mediocre in many areas
in this particular area he's
particularly well suited and in fact if
you said in what scenario should we be
the most happy that it's joe biden and
not donald trump
it's exactly the situation saying an
american president has an opportunity to
stop a global calamity that will wreak
absolute havoc on our economy and on
people around the world
that this is the scenario this is the
scenario let's see what happens and
although on the one hand biden agrees in
principle to meet with putin and there
have been reports that such a summit
is going forward
uh the kremlin denies that there are any
concrete plans for a putin biden summit
at this time and so we are going to have
to wait and see what happens there
russian president putin's spokesman said
just hours ago there were no plans yet
for a new summit with joe biden
contradicting claims from the white
house which said the leaders agreed in
principle so that's why the headline on
cnbc is
biden agrees
but so far
kremlin denies and this is going to be a
this is a i would argue this is a bigger
geopolitical test and calamity
really than anything that happened under
trump i mean trump will say well no i
went and met with kim jong-un
and then i got him to make these
promises but
these are the same promises that north
korean leaders have made to american
presidents for a long time and
trump was just so naive in that and i i
think that this is uh this is far far
more than that and you know at the end
of the day just look at the markets
right the markets will tell you what is
the bigger calamity and the markets were
quite calm when the entire north korea
thing was happening the markets are
erratic right now uh know that if biden
meets with putin and putin ends up not
invading and there's no war the
anti-biden are are gonna people are
gonna spin this really really hard you
know they're already calling him a
warmonger now even though biden has
already ruled out that the u.s would
send troops multiple times but it
doesn't matter
and if war is averted here and joe biden
is involved the anti-biden people on the
left and right will say putin was never
going to invade anyway you know those
190 000 troops on three sides of ukraine
they were there on vacation or whatever
biden was just hyping it that's one
thing that they will claim there was
never any risk of invasion anyway uh
they will say you know joe biden is
against our troops because he kept them
from having something to do i mean it
just you know like absurd on its face
they'll say it was really trump's
friendship with putin
before biden that prevented the war
they'll say oh well putin clearly made
some demand of biden and biden accepted
it because biden is so weak or maybe
they'll say rudy called putin secretly
maybe hunter biden's laptop will be
thrown in there or hillary in some way
they'll claim it was the canadian
truckers who convinced putin to back off
or whatever anyway the point is
they will spin this no matter what
happens against joe biden so let's try
to follow the facts of what's happening
right now we have
a very very uh uh sensitive intense
situation there
my hope is
there is no war
and let's see if joe biden can help
prevent that
uh it's not it's not the us's
responsibility to prevent it
but
if joe biden is able to actually get
something done
uh i am all for it and i'm glad that
it's not trump that's being put in that
position
let me know your thoughts
let me know what you expect and i mean
you know things are moving so quickly
that by the time this clip publishes
russia may have already been invaded may
have already invaded ukraine um let me
know find me on twitter at deepakman
we'll be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is independent
media we are not part of some media
conglomerate we don't have
funding for the show in the sense that
some company gives us studio space and
bandwidth and equipment uh it's all just
our small team it's it's me doing this
show and our small team
uh producing it on a daily basis and we
really depend primarily on you to fund
our operation so i would love it if you
got a membership on my website
joinpakman.com
you'll get access to the daily bonus
show which alex jones hates oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad he doesn't like it it
definitely makes me think of it that's
really an endorsement in my mind of the
bonus show you'll also get a commercial
free audio and video stream of the show
every day
six hours before the show is made public
sign up at joinpacman.com
i want to make a goal of mine publicly
known so that you can hold me to it you
know one of the best ways to actually
get something done is to tell other
people that you plan to do it and my
goal is to stop explaining myself to
idiots now you might say whoa sir that's
very aggressive language what do you
mean
in order to try to save myself
from thousands of horrible comments
tweets and emails
i will often over explain things and
give disclaimers
and i really am only doing that
to people who were just nuts or are bad
faith actors so like when i say hey guys
you know in the in the russia ukraine
thing putin's the aggressor but to be
clear i don't support american
imperialism i don't think the u.s is a
perfect actor with an unblemished record
of foreign uh foreign relations i do not
favor the u.s sending troops to ukraine
i do not think the u.s should choose the
leaders in other countries and all of
those disclaimers are really for like
five percent of my audience now i wish
it was like one percent or less but it
is about five percent of the audience
but it's a very loud five percent it's a
very weaponized five percent but most of
you know that i don't mean invade russia
when i say putin is being the aggressor
here and likewise when i say you know
i can't support
the former
chavez now maduro regime in venezuela
because they've raped and pillaged the
country's resources for themselves while
spewing false populist rhetoric about
how they're going to help everybody and
meanwhile people can't even afford food
which there are shortages of anyway
i don't mean invade venezuela i don't
mean assassinate maduro i don't mean
that the u.s should pick who is the
leader in venezuela i only mean
i don't like maduro 95 of you get that
but the five percent that don't or
refuse to are really loud and really
annoying but this isn't normal
this isn't a normal way to talk about
things and this is sadly a toxic reality
of the internet this is kind of like how
twitter works and social media
all these platforms select and and
highlight
reactionaries and outrageous responses
to content i'll give you kind of like a
benign example i post a picture of
myself having a cappuccino at a coffee
shop in los angeles the way i did two
months ago this was on instagram not
twitter
99 of the people who see me with my
stupid cappuccino
say nothing i never hear from 99
of the people who see that picture
one percent leave a comment
90 of the comments are completely normal
weather looks great looks great have fun
yeah whatever okay
of the comments okay so we're talking
ten percent of the one percent the
people who choose to comment of those
comments ten percent people go
crazy
david you're traveling during a pandemic
you're so irresponsible how dare you you
know people died of covet today
the other one
you're not wearing a mask david
si you don't
you don't care about other people you're
so self-centered that you drink a
cappuccino with no mask
and
number three
are you drinking cow's milk
how are you not a vegan you're a
terrible person
um it's not normal and social media
really skews this because
most people see a guy with a coffee and
they move on with their day but the
internet has created this almost
defensive status quo for posting
anything and on my show i'm in this
defensive mode
whenever i comment on stuff even though
anybody normal or acting in good faith
realizes these are not normal reactions
and that i'm not saying
whatever the worst faith possible
interpretation of my words actually is
so my new effort is going to be
not to do the disclaimers and the
defensiveness when i just give my
opinion about things on the show because
at the end of the day
not only is it preposterous to cater to
people who are quite frankly nuts or bad
faith actors it also won't stop them
from saying the exact same things i've
got an example for you
look at the comments
on my recent russia clips in those
videos i say putin is the aggressor
but i'm not an imperialist
i don't want war
i don't want u.s troops there i don't
want u.s involvement beyond you know if
nato as an organization says well we're
going to support ukraine in some way i
don't want the u.s doing regime change
and i look at the video
and i see comments like the ones i'm i'm
putting up on the screen for you right
now
you're just repeating establishment
talking points and neocon lies david i'm
not imperialist but let's have war
now i i did the disclaimers and i still
got the comment next comment you are an
imperialist
no no no i i explained it
another comment tulsi is a twisted
grifter but you're brazenly lying
warmongering imperialist trash david
i'm gonna do my best because either way
they're gonna say that stuff
so at the end of the day
i don't do the show for that crazy five
percent
i'm doing the show for the good faith 95
percent so the other five percent can
quite frankly you know go go to wherever
hold me to it keep me honest okay i
appreciate that hey guys listen uh i
wish ivermectin worked for covid i i
wish hydroxychloroquine worked for covid
i wish
a zpac zipthromycin worked for covid i i
really do because these things are cheap
and ubiquitous but we have to operate in
the real world
and no matter what
marjorie taylor greene or joe rogan or
anyone says about a medication
the way we determine whether a
medication works for covid is you do a
randomized controlled trial with a
placebo arm and then it's peer reviewed
and published and then we have data
okay
uh it's not some doctor in france gave
hydroxy to 30 people that's not that's
not the way we do it okay
we look at peer-reviewed rcts
we now have that for ivermectin we have
a study just published called
efficacy of ivermectin treatment on
disease progression among adults with
mild to moderate covid and comorbidities
we have a study
read the study it's not super long it
will tell you everything you need to
know about ivermectin for covet the
question that the study asked is does
adding ivermectin to the standard of
care
because remember you always want to test
things against the standard of care does
adding ivermectin to the standard of
care reduce the risk of severe disease
in patients with covet and comorbidities
well the findings in this open label
randomized clinical trial of high-risk
patients
with covet in malaysia a five-day course
of oral ivermectin was administered
during the first week of illness and it
did not reduce the risk of developing
severe disease compared with the
standard of care alone that this is
called this is a science okay this is
what we call a science
conclusions and relevance in this
randomized clinical trial of high-risk
patients with mild to moderate covid
ivermectin treatment during early
illness did not prevent progression to
severe disease
the study findings do not support the
use of ivermectin
for patients with covid19
this is it
now
would be the responsible
time if you promoted ivermectin to make
sure your followers know it doesn't work
because there are lots of people who
only get their medical advice
from people like you know hannity
joe rogan whoever
so they should now say
we've been wondering about ivermectin we
have a proper
peer-reviewed
rct
ivermectin doesn't work we tested it now
there are some people who will say yeah
but david that was only tested on people
over 50 with comorbidities those are the
people at risk like the same people who
say take ivermectin
are the people who say
you don't need to worry about this if
you're healthy or young you just don't
and and that's mostly statistically true
so
why would you want to test divermectin
on people who don't need to do anything
to recover from covid with no problem
whatsoever so we need treatment for the
people more likely to die that's why it
was tested on these people by the way
for things that do work
it's not just that anything cheap
david's against anything that was
mentioned early david's against
vitamin d
we've been talking about vitamin d and
covid for a long time and it's not clear
whether taking vitamin d is protective
or whether getting covered lowers your
vitamin e but there is now a study
which says vitamin d levels appear to be
important when it comes to covin
a new study that considers pre-infection
vitamin d levels confirms their link to
severe disease we have identified that
yes it's not just covet lowers vitamin d
if you have a lower vitamin d level
before getting covered your risk of
severe covet is higher now the
researchers say the findings don't
necessarily imply
vitamin d treatment will
impact outcomes but they suggest
maintaining a normal level of vitamin d
this is cheap this is a great thing
right i tested myself for vitamin d
right at the end of winter of 2020 when
this was all getting going because there
was the suspicion that there might be
something vitamin d related i my vitamin
you want a vitamin d level of 30.
i tested myself and i was at 30. so from
october through april
i supplement vitamin d a thousand units
per day i checked with my doctor my
doctor said that amount is fine you're
not going to experience vitamin d
toxicity that's a great thing to do it
may or may not be protective but having
a good vitamin d level can't hurt
and
it may be something that is worth doing
and it's really cheap the wright loves
to say no one wants to recommend cheap
stuff like ivermectin that you can do
now vitamin d is cheap and it sounds
like it's worth doing
of course talk to your doctor before
starting it there might be something
about your situation where your doctor
would say don't supplement vitamin d but
vitamin d is really cheap and it is now
being looked at more and more strongly
so what i want is to do things that are
shown to work
and that's the most important thing
ivermectin study
doesn't work for covet
anybody who promoted it should make sure
their followers know we have a study and
it doesn't work don't seek out
ivermectin for covet
we'll have more on this on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
we'll take a very quick break
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com david pakman show in
the midst of just a packed weekend of
news involving russia ukraine and the
possibility of a biden putin summit and
so many other things
it almost got lost
that a judge has determined donald trump
and his children will have to answer
questions under oath as part of an
investigation this is a massive massive
story a new york judge shot down a bid
to block the state attorney general's
subpoenas of the former president donald
trump jr and ivanka trump that this is a
massive massive story
a judge ordered former president donald
trump and two of his children thursday
to answer questions under oath about the
trump organization's business practices
in the state attorney general's civil
probe against the company remember this
is a civil probe civil
um not uh not criminal
lawyers for trump trump jr and ivanka
wanted to quash the subpoenas from
letitia james's office arguing the
investigation is politically motivated
and designed to provide fuel for an
ongoing criminal probe into the company
by the manhattan district attorney's
office in his ruling state supreme court
justice arthur engeron
gave the green light for the three to be
deposed within the next three weeks he
also ordered the former president to
turn over documents and information
subpoenaed within two weeks and
portrayed the trump's claim of being
selectively targeted as overblown
the trump lawyers indicated at a hearing
that they would appeal if angeron let
the depositions proceed quote there is a
likelihood that we will appeal said alan
feuderfass the attorney for trump's kids
what could happen
if they ultimately do testify
is something called taking the fifth
taking the fifth the associated press
reporting the choice could soon be
trump's in a new york probe
to plead the fifth or not that is the
question donald trump may face
trump's lawyers are almost certain to
appeal the decision
barring a successful legal challenge
trump would face a decision between
answering questions under oath
or remaining silent and invoking his
fifth amendment right a tactic he has
equated with evidence of guilt remember
that
remember trump's previous statements
about people who plead the fifth just a
reminder
fifth amendment
bob
the mob takes effect
if you're innocent why are you taking
the fifth amendment fifth amendment
horrible
horrible the mob takes if ever
if you're innocent why are you taking
the fifth amendment wow that's a that's
a fair point uh and donald trump uh
speaking about it regularly during the
campaign
her staffers taking the fifth amendment
how about that
and her ring leaders getting immunities
now
she has people taking the fifth
amendment
four people plus
the guy who illegally did the server you
know he put in the illegal server right
so there are five people taking the
fifth amendment like you see on the mob
right right i see the mob takes it
if you're innocent why are you taking
the fifth amendment that is a beautiful
question now we all know what trump's
going to say if he ends up taking the
fifth he will say no no no listen
those people
were being legitimately looked at
because they did things that were wrong
and they took the fifth so
they're using the fifth is evidence of
their guilt
but for me
these are unfair politically motivated
witch hunts so it's totally different my
analysis of people pleading the fifth
and that making you look guilty
that's only the case
if you're not me if you're me it's all
politically motivated and blah blah blah
this is genuinely a problem for the
trump family and i think again i want to
restate this is all related to a civil
case not a criminal case
but um it is
important in that it could set precedent
as to whether trump could similarly be
forced to and or
answer questions under oath
in a criminal case and we know that
there are multiple investigations uh
looking into whether donald trump has
committed crimes not just civil
infractions or has civil liability so
we're obviously going to be following
this really closely
not the news that trump was hoping for
and this sent trump into full panic mode
and we're going to look at his statement
next okay so we're going to move on from
this trump having to testify under oath
thing because at the end of the day
we don't know what's going to happen and
even if he does have to testify he'll
probably just plead the fifth
but donald trump was heavily triggered
by the decision made by a judge
just as the weekend was starting that in
the civil investigation into donald
trump's organization trump
don jr and ivanka
have to testify under oath and they
should do so within the next three weeks
trump's lawyers may appeal it we still
don't know what's going to happen
donald trump
lost his mind over this
and this to me reads like a sign of
major major panic
statement by donald trump and this is a
mouthful okay i'm gonna try to deliver
it to you as written here we go
so crooked hillary clinton one of the
most corrupt politicians ever to run for
president can break into the white house
my apartment buildings i own and my
campaign in other words she can spy on a
presidential candidate and ultimately
the president of the united states and
the now totally discredited fake news
media does everything they can not to
talk about it that's one sentence
riddled with about four different lies
hillary didn't break into the white
house didn't break into trump's
apartment didn't break into trump's
buildings and didn't uh break into his
campaign all of this surging from a
mis-characterization
of a report from john durham using the
term infiltrated when durham didn't
actually use the term so this is all
lies and this is the setup and now trump
goes on
to the decision made about his testimony
quote on the other hand failed
gubernatorial candidate leticia james
can run for the office of ag on saying
absolutely horrendous and false things
about donald trump a man she doesn't
know and has never met go on to get
elected and then selectively prosecute
him and his family
after viewing millions of pages of
documents over many years they come up
with the fringe benefits case on a car
an apartment and on grandchildren's
education now remember that is not the
only issue at play in that investigation
a major issue at play is the
misstatement of the value of assets like
buildings a really really big deal but
also yes trump seems to be admitting
that people who worked for him did not
pay taxes on fringe benefits and that's
you can't do that that's not allowed
okay continuing
she is doing everything within their
corrupt discretion to interfere with my
business relationships and with the
political process with the rest of the
case even psy vance who just left the
da's office without prosecuting anything
additional because there isn't anything
additional to prosecute there is no case
the targeting of a pr these are just
sentence fragments strung together in a
febrile screed
the targeting of a president of the
united states who got more votes while
in office than any president in capital
h history by far and is a person that
the capital r radical left democrats
don't want to run again
represents an unconstitutional attack on
our capital c country and the people
will not allow this travesty of justice
to happen what people what are you
talking about
it is a continuation of the greatest
capital w witch hunt in history and
remember i can't get a fair hearing in
new york because of the hatred of me by
capital j judges
and the judiciary it is not possible
folks this is this is full-blown panic
this is full-blown panic at this point
in time and this guy is absolutely
losing it now later in the show we are
going to get to the confirmation that
yes
trump took
classified documents to his house
and would regularly flush them down his
potty
it it's been confirmed okay we're going
to get to that after the break
but this guy is in such an escalated
situation emotionally because of what's
going on
that he's liable to do things we can't
even imagine over the next few weeks
this guy will do everything he can to
avoid being put under oath
and having to answer questions because
he also knows yeah i mean listen
he'll plead the fifth if that's what it
comes to he will and it'll be totally
hypocritical given his previous comments
that you plead the fifth if you're
guilty which by the way if you believe
in due process law and order in the
constitution your silence can't be used
against you
it and but trump has he almost considers
it axiomatic that
if you plead the fifth you're guilty
which is the opposite of what a guy who
claims to be for law and order should be
saying if you claim to be for the
constitution due process and law and
order you'd be saying no no no pleading
pleading the fifth is not evidence of
guilt
now of course colloquially all of us can
understand there are situations where if
you have nothing to hide you would just
show up and answer questions we we can
understand that that's a colloquialism
that is a reality uh but this guy is
going to do everything he can to be
avoid being put in that situation to
begin with and we will be following it
all the way down to the bottom after the
break
it is now confirmed the national
archives has confirmed
trump took classified documents to his
house
it's been turned over to the justice
department
and the justice department is
investigating we'll take a quick break
let me know your thoughts about this
story
find us on facebook at facebook.com
david pakman show
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
rarely a day is going by certainly not a
week where we don't learn
yet another element of the absurdity and
insanity and in some cases the
criminality that allegedly took place
during the trump administration you have
been following the story if you've been
watching the show listening to the show
of donald trump taking classified
documents to mar-a-lago flushing
documents incinerating documents no word
yet on whether he smoked or sauteed any
but that would be the next shoe to drop
the national archives have now confirmed
and turned over to the justice
department that donald trump did take
classified items to his house at
mar-a-lago and the projection all along
has just been stunning
remember
hillary clinton can't be trusted her
emails
private email
she would be irresponsible with
sensitive and classified documents well
then trump during his presidency goes
and spills secrets to a russian spy
recruiter sergey kislyak in the oval
office trump's family like ivanka and
jared kushner and others using private
email for white house business trump
ripping up presidential records which
people come in and tape back together
trump sending documents in burn bags to
the pentagon to be incinerated which are
to be kept by the presidential records
act according to the presidential
records act trump flushing documents
down the toilet clogging it having to
call maintenance to unclog the toilet
and yes
he took classified documents to his
house
national archives ap report trump took
classified items to mar-a-lago
classified information
was found in the 15 boxes of white house
records that were stored at former
president donald trump's mar-a-lago
residents the national archives
said friday in a letter that confirms
the matter has been sent to the justice
department that's called
possible criminality
the letter from the agency follows
numerous reports around trump's handling
of sensitive and even classified
information during his time as president
and after he left the white house the
revelation could also interest federal
investigators for policing the handling
of government secrets though the justice
department and fbi have not indicated
they will pursue
federal law bars the removal of
classified documents to unauthorized
locations though it is possible that
trump could try to argue that as
president he was the ultimate
declassification
authority
so there's a couple different things
here and some of you have written to me
and said david the classified nature
doesn't matter only the violations of
the presidential records act matter
because trump as the president can
declassify anything that's up for legal
dispute
uh spoke to a couple lawyers who said
so yes trump can declassify anything
that he wants
however he didn't declassify these
things he just took them and there is
this weird
in-between situation where there's the
violation of the presidential records
act
there is an issue with him taking
classified documents although he could
declassify them but merely taking them
doesn't by definition declassify them
it's a legal matter to sort out
but looking backwards everything trump
talked about others doing
he was doing he said hillary will do all
of this stuff no no no you will do it
and you did do it remember the toilet
ran we all sought
why is trump talking about toilets over
and over and over again
he's
obsessed with the fact that toilets
aren't flushing like they used to
and now maybe we know remember this we
have a
situation where we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers
and other elements of bathrooms
where
you turn the faucet on in areas where
there's tremendous amounts of water
where the water rushes out to sea
because you could never handle it
and you don't get any water you turn on
the faucet you don't get any water
they
take a shower and water comes dripping
out it's dripping out very
quietly dripping out
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once they end up using
more water right
trump's complaints about good old
toilets just aren't flushing the way
they used to
for all we know it was because he was
trying to flush documents down the
toilet
and it was getting clogged
and he was having to call maintenance so
this is this is all as bad as anything
he said anybody else was doing um
consider also how in the meantime fox
news has barely barely covered this
story
but they did mention hillary clinton
like a hundred times over the weekend on
the basis of the supposed durham report
we're gonna get to that in a moment so
at the end of the day uh trump could
have declassified these documents so
that he would not have been stealing
classified documents as the president he
does have the ultimate authority to
declassify there is this kind of weird
in-between status he definitely violated
the presidential records act that we
know
um and no one would believe this if it
weren't all completely true it's too
absurd if you wrote a screenplay about a
wacky president and you included a scene
of him flushing documents down the
toilet after accusing his opponent of
being untrustworthy with documents
it would be like you can't do it it's
too it's too much it's too cliche it's
too absurd no one would believe it no
one would do it it is real life folks
it's real real life and that's what's
going on okay let's talk about the
durham report
many of you wrote to me and you said
david or you actually many of you did
not say david many of you used
pejoratives and anti-semitic terms for
me and but still said
you won't
talk about the durham report which has
uh implicated hillary clinton in
stealing and spying and being in trump's
white house and all these different
things
this story
has gotten more and more oxygen
and generated more and more stories
and yet
all of the basis for it
is bogus and has been debunked so what
am i talking about i'm talking about
a
series of headlines based on a court
filing by john durham john durham his
special counsel doing an investigation
into
did anyone spy on trump and you know
some other different things
and headlines exploded a few days ago
saying
hillary infiltrated the trump white
house
wow
that's pretty strong hillary infiltrated
where did they get that well they said
the durham filing with the court says
hillary infiltrated and spied and did
all these different things
except remember my
acronym caps
critically analyze primary sources if
you find the court filing you go sir
where is the word infiltrate where is
even a word that means infiltrate and
it's not there because it's not in the
report
the headlines using the word infiltrate
were then used for further reporting so
you would look on fox and they would go
headline
it was all bogus okay
there was an event in texas over the
weekend
madison cothorn marjorie taylor green
were there
and they're just making stuff up out of
thin air in this first clip you'll see
marjorie taylor green say
that hillary also hacked the white house
the hillary campaign hacked the white
house now of course understand that
there was no hillary campaign in trump
white house at the same time what what i
mean by that is
by the time that there was a trump white
house
there was no hillary campaign because
the campaign ended months before there
was a trump white house doesn't matter
you know explain to them time doesn't
work the way you they don't care take a
look at this so let's hope it goes
faster than this durham report and all
of that right wasn't that a beauty yeah
i mean can you guys believe that here we
are how many years later this is 2022
and we're still hearing the truth come
out about how the hillary clinton
campaign spied on candidate donald j
trump and then even further they hacked
into the white house and spied on the
president there is no evidence of that
and it is not what the durham court
filing says the united states and then
here we're you know it's still coming
out it's shameful i mean honestly what
really should happen is hillary clinton
should be in jail now of course
they believe in due process
the first thing would be well you would
charge hillary
that would be the first step and it's
for a jury to decide whether she should
be in jail
it's not up to marjorie taylor green
they say that they are all about law and
order and they call for the imprisonment
not only of people who haven't been
found guilty of people who haven't even
been charged and every single person
that worked on her campaign and was
involved in spying on a president of the
united states i don't care about
political parties i don't care about any
of it when people will go that far to
try to win and defeat their political
opponents they belong in jail and and
right now we're in a time where we're
seeing um
you know people abusing power and going
after their political enemies
we are seeing that but we're seeing it
from the trumpian delusion or the the
delusional trumpist wing of the party
she's a member of
there are people that did break laws and
they have been charged for the riot on
january 6th but right now they're still
locked up in jail in the dc jail they're
now they care about pre-trial detention
all of a sudden pre-trial january 6
defendants they deserve their due
process
rights they deserve to be treated uh uh
innocent until proven guilty
it is just unbelievable
they deserve their due process rights
imprison hillary despite no indictment
charges trial or guilty verdict
but the rioters aren't being treated
properly now of course we've been
talking about the issue of pre-trial
detention for years these people never
cared about it and there's actually work
to be done we're on the precipice of a
war between russia and ukraine that will
throw energy
supply chains and the stock market into
chaos and rattle the american economy
cause inflation cause chaos and they've
spent days talking about a hillary story
based on a distorted report
which did not summarize what was
actually in the durham filing on the
basis of which dozens of stories and
hours of reporting uh were based
and they say that we're the ones who
aren't talking about the real issues
here's one other clip from this same
very strange event in texas
here marjorie taylor green tells the lie
that ukraine was the top donor to
hillary clinton's campaign
it it's just it's pulled out of thin air
it's not true hides them all um the
media would rather tell you lies about
people like us
call us all kinds of horrible names um
present some character of us that is not
even true so that people will think bad
things about us but they don't want to
tell the truth uh so many stories like
the truth about what's actually
happening in our country but yet they'd
rather talk about russia russia russia
and ukraine and and talk about possible
war than talk about the real truth
that's a real story marge there that the
russia ukraine story is something that's
actually happening
there's nothing about hillary
infiltrating the trump white house it's
it's just there's no actual basis for
that that ukraine don't forget this
ukraine was the number one donor to
hillary clinton no
no ukraine was not the number one donor
to hillary clinton i don't even really
know what that means
until these people
are sued and actually lose a defamation
suit
they will not stop
one thing that has dramatically reduced
the number of these hillary stories uh
on fox and among some other and right
with some other right-wing media outlets
is that at a speech in new york over the
weekend
hillary clinton said
what is being said about her is
approaching actual malice now that is
a legal term relevant to defamation
remember that in the case where sarah
palin sued the new york times for
defamation last week a judge determined
there was no proof of actual malice and
malice actual malice is very hard to
prove under under you know admittedly
hillary clinton's saying what they're
doing is approaching actual malice
seems to have
made some of these right-wing media
people realize
we may be going a little too far here
particularly because all of our
apoplectic headlines about hillary and
spying and infiltrating are based on
bogus interpretations of the durham
court filing so it's it's not going to
stop until somebody loses a defamation
suit that you can be sure of we have a
voicemail number that number is a number
you can call anytime
if you have anything you want to tell me
the number is 219
to
david p
219
to david p that's 219 232
8
here's a caller asking why i won't
debate
without considering
another possibility take a listen
hey davey boy i just it's me again i see
you haven't responded to me ever so i'm
just gonna
give you this one
question okay i don't know anything
about other voicemails this is the only
voicemail i'm aware of from this guy
why don't you ever
debate people who are actually smarter
than you like ben shapiro or kansas
owens or kim klasik
hey i don't know who that kim kleisick i
don't know the first two i know maybe
even larry elder
because you know there
or i have a better idea debate dave
rubin sure or chad hannity or the
smartest person of them all tucker
carlson okay because you know
just wondering bye yeah
i am glad to debate any of them have you
ever considered maybe they
don't have an interest in debating me
either because they see me as not worth
their time or for whatever reason don't
want to
as many of you might remember
at the political
media conference politicon a couple
years ago
i was told by organizers you and kyle
kulinski
will be debating charlie kirk and
candace owens and i said great i'll be
there
we then found out that candace owens has
not did not accept that offer
later candace said
i didn't wasn't even presented with that
offer now
politicon does often do this thing where
they try to play people off of each
other and they go hey we've got candace
and charlie to debate you you want to do
it and then you go yes
then they go to charles
charles charlie and candace and they go
hey david pakman and kyle kalinski want
to debate you and they go no no we're
not interested they sometimes they do
lie about who is accepted it's
unfortunately a common tactic
maybe candace owens turned it down maybe
she didn't but the point here is
a lot of these folks have no interest in
debating me dave rubin is welcome on
this show anytime i tried to get on his
show when i was in l.a and he you know
didn't want to do it he was busy
whatever so
for a second stop to think that
maybe it's the other people who don't
want to debate me
i don't know something to think about we
have a great bonus bonus show for you
today
today is the launch date for the truth
social app this is trump's new social
media app it looks just like twitter i
tried to sign up
couldn't do it we're going to talk about
it it's a very interesting uh
interesting project
the us
is now
energy independent from the standpoint
of petroleum production and consumption
wait a second i thought trump said we're
no longer energy independent but we were
under him well we've got the facts
and joe biden has cancelled 415
million dollars of student loans
making him the president who has
canceled the most student loans of any
president in history now we should
inflation adjust that of course
very interesting stories all of which
will be on two days bonus show which you
can sign up for at joinpacman.com
also next monday
i will be delivering the state of the
show address
on tuesday next tuesday joe biden is
delivering the state of the union
address i will be delivering on monday
the state of the show address and it is
going to be
inspirational
it is going to be
thematic in many ways related to things
on the show uh it's gonna be very very
good i look forward to sharing with you
what's been going on at the david pakman
show we will see you tomorrow or if you
are a member at joinpacman.com
the bonus show starts
in mere minutes